when it comes to covert 19 there are
lots of different statistics but perhaps
the most important number of all
is the r number the reproduction number
it gives you a sense of how many people
every given person with disease might be
passing it on to when you look at the uk
how that's evolved you can see it's come
down an awful lot from the early phase
of the pandemic over three
so three people for every person who had
the disease might get it off them
down to below one and it's that one
point which is so crucial below that
you're not
seeing the exponential increase in the
disease but look more recently it
started to creep up and now according to
the government
up to 1.1 to 1.4 it equates to growth of
about two to seven percent and that's
more or less what we're hearing from
other sources
as well so a different measure of this
is this ons survey
the office of national statistics
looking at how many new cases we're
seeing
and they're talking about new cases
being around 6 000
a day it looks like a steep increase but
bear in mind what we're talking about
here
is it doubling every 10 days it's going
up
but back in the early phase of this
pandemic we're talking about a hundred
thousand new cases every day we were
talking about it doubling every
two days three days so this is very very
different
although it certainly is on the rise
when you look across different parts of
the uk we've got this map here a heat
map the darker the areas the more
clovered 19
you're seeing what we'll see is there
are certain hot spots and bolton we've
heard a little bit about
213 cases per hundred thousand it is way
above most of the other areas
in the uk look for instance at
warrington so we're seeing new
restrictions there but it is 105 cases
per hundred thousand so a lot less than
bottom but nonetheless
uh going up and quite a high level but
there are some parts of the country
where actually we're seeing cases
going down so swindon was on the watch
list until not that long ago
but now it's down to 13 cases per
hundred thousand so some areas they are
able to get
the level down but when we take a step
back and try and think about where we
might be headed
it's worth just looking at a few other
countries because we know that the
disease
is also spreading in france that's where
france is at the moment up to about
eight nine thousand new cases a day
right now
spain is in a similar kind of trajectory
up above ten thousand cases
a day so it's worth just working out
where the uk sits and let's have a look
at our line actually we are more or less
in line with those trajectories that's
where we are right now
but it's quite probable that in a few
weeks time
in the uk we could be up to 10 000 cases
a day now
that is potentially very scary but on
the other hand
there is a bit of good news out of spain
they are starting to to bring the growth
rate of cases
down so it does look for the time being
as if the outbreak
it's rising but it's not rising anywhere
like as fast as it did in the spring